Yeah.
Rolling.
[inaudible]
that's what they decided to do to them
to make it look like they found his body.
He was 22 and I'm sure he was probably
involved with a bunch of waves as the
evening.
Some of the unscrupulous intentions,
you know,
just David Carradine,
he was in conflict with,
he likes to party,
notorious accidental mechanical at
68 was found hogtied wearing too wet
dialing gloves and slippers,
rubberized underwear and a
headmaster pork right here.
Investigations.
Gary all just his death was not caused.
Yeah,
that looks fine.
What's your definition of the 51 year
old pastor wasn't voted as home at the
time.
We'd gone apparently in the mess.
Yeah.
Wow Man.
Yeah,
that's fine.
All right,
we ready?
Oh,
what police?
That's it.
They chose not to mention what police
discovered inside the ministers rubber
briefs.
And if you click on that link
they found a giant black.
So
Ah,
ah,
corked and Jamie here
recording audio of all of this.
Yes.
We're uh,
we're in the kitchen with Tonka trucks.
Haul got allergies or something.
Does the podcast studio has
been transformed because a
big part of the new Scifi
show deals with the podcasts are,
he's in it.
And so it's young Duncan Trussell and uh,
we're filming a lot of the guests
and some of the discussions here,
uh,
at the studio.
So if you could see this is usually
not cluttered and crazy and uh,
they,
they changed the decorations a little.
They gave us this,
this fucking stupid thing.
I don't know what that is,
but it makes it more saifai whatever.
Um,
so today was a doctor Jeffrey Meldrum.
He's a lead shit scientists who
heavily believes in bigfoot,
I don't know,
but fun stuff.
And we'd been going nonstop.
The show starts airing July 16th,
and where,
uh,
the schedule's just been ridiculous,
but we're meeting a lot of really
cool people and so far as Lana,
pretty cool shit.
And that's all the crew back there.
Think of times that a lot of
shit to show you fuckers for.
Shit,
I'm so tired.
I haven't slept right in days.
I've been fine.
All of the fucking world.
I flew from Canada to New York,
New York,
North Carolina,
North Carolina here,
and from here we got to go to Texas.
Dunkin's going to go to or no.
Dot.
He's going to go to Colorado and I got
to go to Texas and then I got to go to
Alaska.
But it's gonna be bad ass.
Hopefully it'll suck either way.
I'll tell you,
I'll create a pseudonym.
I'll go online.
I'll tell you my show stock.
That'd be really obvious though.
They'll be like,
whoa,
job until where are you said telepathy
already exist in the form of language,
right?
With language.
Your mouth is making certain sounds
and then you run those downs through a
cultural context.
A dictionary of sure.
What we've accepted that
those sounds represent.
And through that I can read your mind.
Yeah.
And that's what you're doing.
When you were describing
to me your encounter,
meeting your friend,
and while you're jogging and various
coincidences that have happened through
your life,
I'm essentially reading a
version of your thoughts on the,
on these subjects and dad is telepathy.
And that is what separates
human beings from other animals.
That what we're dealing with as far as
like what we call psychic energy might
just be a,
we are,
we are slowly emerging and we
were slowly developing these,
these potential abilities and a guy like
band a check may be able to come along
and dismiss all of these because they're
not as tangible as a noise that comes
from your mouth.
Maybe it takes a million years to develop
these abilities and maybe right now we
just,
the whispers of these abilities are
possible maybe where it's like a radio
station that you can only
tune in during a thunderstorm,
but it's just like it was tiny weird
phenomenon that only happens like upon
occasion.
That is possible.
It is certainly possible.
And another thing about psychic energy
that makes it fantastic and very
interesting to discuss is the fact
that so many people have claimed to
experience it and so many people I think
almost recognized at a genetic level
that that's coming and that is an emerging
aspect of human consciousness and the
ability to do it nonverbally
yeah,
I mean yeah,
it's one I can say one thing
is indisputable right now.
There is no accepted
proof that this exists.
There's no accepted proof.
We don't know.
We don't know that it exists right now
that is indisputable and that does not
mean that it doesn't exist.
And that's what's really cool about the
scientific method and this approach to
truth is it,
it isn't committed one way or the other.
It's not.
And I don't even think vantage check was
completely closed off to the idea that
it wasn't real.
Yeah,
it was.
I thought for a moment he said,
I don't know,
may,
I thought there was like something in,
they're always like,
it hasn't been proven,
but maybe I don't remember.
Maybe I just,
well thanks for checking.
You might've put that in asleep.
So yeah,
you said me
said maybe it's weird.
I want,
one thing that I love about this show,
what it's done to me is if you think I'm
a hippie now before the show I was much
more of a heavy,
and then you come into contact with
people who are really in believing this
thing or that thing and
won't listen to logic.
And then that becomes really appalling
when you realize that from an
individual's POV it's kind
of sad or cute or whatever.
But from a group of people believing
in things that aren't provable,
that shit gets really bad.
And also I,
one thing that vantage has pointed out,
which I really liked
just how dangerous it is,
a,
when people decide to use methods that
are easily recreated to actually get
money from people and pray
on the their vulnerabilities,
like they miss a loved one,
they show them a few parlor tricks,
makes maybe think that they have these
abilities and then suddenly they're
taking money from them to let them talk
to their grandparents who've done or
their parents have died that's evil.
And then you take that one step further
and you get the priest class who
convinces groups of people
that they can talk to God.
And then they start
churches and religions.
And then the next thing you know
you've got an even deeper problems.
So I think that stuff that vantage
check does and that skeptics do,
it's really important and good.
And it's important to be skeptical,
but you can't be skeptical to the point
where you step on your own experience,
where your skepticism override something
that you've actually experienced.
Yeah.
But isn't it possible that skepticism
not overrides what you've actually
experienced but defines it explains it?
Well,
if,
if it,
if it can be explained,
if it can be explained.
Yeah.
So far everything you've said,
I believe can be explained.
Yeah.
I,
and also just because
something can be explained,
it doesn't mean that
it's no longer special,
are wonderful.
It just means that now
you know what it is.
Yes.
I agree with that.
I think that's really important and I
become much more of a skeptic because of
the show as well.
Um,
and talking to people
that believe in things.
You also recognize these patterns that
exist over and over again and people that
believe in things and it's that they
don't ever contemplate the contrary.
They don't,
they don't ever consider whether or
not what they believe in is nonsense.
They just go forward with sort of this,
this blind conviction that what they're,
whether it's about aliens or psychics
or big foot or whatever it's about,
they go forth with this conviction that
they have the truth and they want to
expose the truth.
I think that can function
because of his head sled
over until I can come.
Cause when you touch my butt,
who wants to live forever?
Yeah,
let's kill life after life still running.
We're rolling
white terror,
silver.
Come by.
Fear.